I don't think I'm gonna make it I've
prepped a little bit up until I started
drinking beers and then I had some fish
tacos and then I had a lot more beers
I've stuck with my weight since I was in
second grade I'm now 23 and then since
about January I've taken a serious
investment into my health and my
nutrition given what I usually eat what
I've been eating the last few days has
been miraculous my meals tend to usually
be pretty healthy but everything in
between is absolutely terrible so this
is all today they've all got numbers on
them so I'm not going to screw them up
got white juice a lot so I think I'm
going to enjoy drinking them what
happens I ready to drink all of them in
the next 20 minutes I think it's gonna
be an adventure of sorts all I want is
like - your sandwich sandwich maybe it's
sad I have a serious aversion to
cilantro
that's what they're eating
this is what I you like that one I
haven't tried that one yet you don't
know I think beets taste like dirt I
like the first three the best one by far
is number three which is called liquid
gold and it is delicious
I like the spicy one the best that's my
jam the last three juices of the day
have like two pounds of produce in them
so they're much harder to drink the
reason most people drink like vegetable
juices I think is not for flavor but is
for the way that it makes you feel
yesterday there were times when I was
just like I could just eat I could just
go to the McDonald's across the street
and just be done with this but now I've
sort of pushed through that phase and
I'll be like no I can I can handle this
walking around the office to get my
juice and we have free lunch today
there's still eat stupid juice I've
heard that kind of between your first
and second day you hit like a fatigue
stage and I think I'm selasa it's a
really weird feeling to not be hungry
but to want food very badly I didn't
realize how much of my daily happiness
food gave me to get me through the juice
cleanse I wanted to have a physical
representation of my progress I've just
hit like a level of apathy about the
whole thing I'm feeling fine like I feel
I wake up in the mornings and just like
oh well I guess I drink juice today I
just had a lot of trouble focusing
yesterday my brain was pre foggy until
late in the afternoon it's hard to
articulate like the kind of fatigue I
feel I'm ready for it to be over but I'm
not like dying to eat either I made it I
survived I'm still just kind of tired
and don't feel especially healthy or
more like in touch with my body but it
was a good exercise I don't think of
three-day-long juice cleanses for me I
already eat a really healthy and
balanced diet that includes a lot of
vegetables and already includes juice
the past three days were the right kind
of kick in the ass I needed to start
eating healthy again the one thing I
think it did help me with was discipline
you can say no to those
snacks you can say no to that soda I am
drinking juice today I do kind of miss
it juice cleanses have their time in
place
[Music]